foreign
[Music]
Google Cloud virtual private cloud or
VPC Network peering allows private
connectivity across two VPC networks so
that workloads in different VPC networks
can communicate with each other
since VPC Network pairing uses Andromeda
Google's implementation of sdn and
Google infrastructure for private IP
connectivity it offers several
advantages like better security low
Network latency and low Network address
cost you may encounter errors with VPC
peering if not configured correctly or
if certain considerations are not
followed today I'll walk you through how
to troubleshoot and resolve some common
issues with BBC Network peering and
share some key points to be considered
while creating or managing VPC Network
period
for today's demo consider the following
topology VPC a and vpcb created in the
same project vpca has subnet a with IP
range
10.0.1.0 24 and subnet x with iprange
10.0.10.0 24. it also has instance a and
a static route route a for 4.2.2.2
associated with subnet a
similarly vpcb has subnet p with an IP
range
10.0.2.0 24 and subnet y with IP range
10.0.10.0 24. it also has instance b and
a static route route B for
8.8.8.8 associated with subnet B let's
start with the first issue unable to
create VPC Network peering I'll set up a
VPC Network appearing from VPC a to vpcb
and from vpcb to VPC a in the Google
Cloud console go to VPC Network select
VPC Network peering click create
connection click continue setup VPC
Network peering from VPC a to vpcb
Import and Export subnet routes with
privately used public ipv4 addresses
click create the network pairing will be
an inactive State until we configure
Network peering from vpcb to vpca use
the same process and create network
pairing from vpcb to vpca click create
peering connection click continue
oops we are getting an error while
creating the pairing it says an IP range
in the peer Network
10.0.10.0 24 overlaps with an IP range
in the local network the subnet IP
ranges in peer VPC networks cannot
overlap in our example subnet X in VPC a
and subnet Y in vpcb I have overlapping
IP ranges to fix this issue I'll remove
subnet y from vpcb and try again
there you go both the VPC Network
keyrings are created and are in active
State another common issue is all or
some custom static or dynamic routes are
not imported to the pr VPC Network this
can happen due to various reasons let's
check one by one static routes in a peer
Network that use Network tags are never
imported as peering custom routes in our
case we don't have static routes with
network tags static routes in peer
Network that use default internet
gateway as the next hub are never
imported as peering custom routes let's
go to each bearing and check imported
and exported custom routes
yeah
subnet routes have been exported to the
peer Network and have been imported from
the peer Network custom route route a
for
4.2.2.2 is neither exported by the
network nor imported by the peer this is
because custom routes are imported by a
peer Network only if export custom
routes option on the VPC peering is
selected in the Network that has the
custom routes and the import custom
routes option on the VPC peering is
selected in the peer Network that should
be receiving the custom routes both
these options are unselected in our
setup let's enable the options and check
again
yeah the custom routes are exported by
the network and accepted by the peer
apart from this keep in mind that when a
network reaches the per peering group
limit of dynamic routes no more routes
can be imported in such cases peering
Dynamic routes might be dropped however
it is not possible to determine which
routes are omitted you need to contact
Google Cloud support in this case now in
our setup let's have another VPC vpcc
which is paired with vpcb and vice versa
so effectively we have a VPC Network
pairing between VPC a and vpcb as well
as between vpcb and vpcc one common
issue that can be seen with this setup
is vpca and vpcc cannot communicate with
each other in fact this is not an issue
but a constraint only directly peered
networks can communicate because
transitive peering is not supported with
VPC peer to resolve this issue and have
connectivity between VPC a and vpcc we
need to configure separate VPC Network
peering from VPC a to TCC and from vpcc
to vpca to conclude I would like to
share some key points to be considered
while configuring VPC Network peering
and troubleshooting any issues a VPC
Network can pair with multiple VPC
networks but there is a limit review VPC
Network peering results you cannot bear
two different auto mode VPC networks
because all Automotive VPC networks have
the exact same subnets each side of a
peering connection is set up
independently peering will become active
only when configuration matches on both
sides only directly peered networks can
communicate transitive peering is not
supported you can't disable the subnet
route exchange or select which subnet
routes are exchanged the subnet IP
ranges in peered VPC networks cannot
overlap VPC players always export subnet
routes for more information on VPC
Network pairing check out this
documentation thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]